howdy y'all wait let me fix some of my setup hello howdy
howdy howdy dody I had a convention I'm at a convention this
weekend in Texas y'all but not one single person has said
that they know sandy cheeks Weird.
OMG, it's a mint!
It's mint!
Where's the swimsuit?
Okay, for those who don't know, uh, we were just watching
Ayami Sensei's panel.
Where she drew me?
She Drew V?
I think maybe Isekai version or
I have a screenshot that I was going to post on Twitter that
um it has a funny face that she made too
Just, uh...
Do you see the resemblance?
Hmm.
I finally got a flight at a long beach.
No way!
You finally got one!
Oh my gosh, Big Mac.
Oh my gosh.
Please go home.
Who is this?
It's me.
I'm really in love with the Asana face she gave me, though.
Where'd those come from?
I don't know.
Here they are.
My two big...
Bulgin.
My eyes are here.
I stand by what I said.
Even when it wasn't me who said it.
Play MGS5 first, everyone, for the true experience.
No!
I had a panel even.
I talked about Metal Gear.
I'm laying saying this is a happy anniversary.
Thank you, Luda!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
You gave me the Wisp plushie, right?
I beat it up every day.
Take out my aggression.
you know.
Homer, I've made my choice.
Vivi Korra, thank you for the five gifted.
And M.
Draygo, thank you for the 20 gifted.
And Oddball Boy, thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
She hates us.
Whisp plushie.
Was I supposed to say that?
Maybe I shouldn't have said that.
Wow, this is how thanks for the five gifters!
So glad your MGS panel was streamed.
It was really fun.
Really?
It wasn't...
It was...
I'm glad...
I gave you the whispers.
Glad you're beating it up.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, Arty!
Happy belated anniversary!
Thank you!
It's too much!
It's too much.
Thank you for that question.
Thank you!
Min-to-chan, oh-ho-ohayao!
Oh-hoaya!
I'm cursed by EU time zones by happy birthday.
That's- I'm streaming a little early today.
SSR Min-to Summer Real.
Yeah.
Wait, what's the other rest?
Oh, Super Summer Real.
Super Summer Real Min-to.
Maybe she'll post the finished version on Twitter.
Let's draw a VEZ.
Thank you for the 20 gift.
Thank you!
I had a buddy who was at the panel.
He had an absolute blast.
He said, thanks.
Oh, man.
I didn't...
I don't make panels, so I didn't really know what to do at
all.
I had no idea what to say.
I was like, I can't make this like a...
How...
No everything about Metal Gear.
Like, I just was like, oh, well, I'll just talk about Metal
Gear.
and then it's hard to do solo panels.
Yeah, like I didn't want to be like, okay, the history of
Metal Gear Solid.
I wanted it to be like a little bit more
a little more silly, I think.
You did well alone?
Okay, I'm glad.
Love the fighting second?
Thank you.
I saw it on Twitch, ignoring an important work meeting.
No!
But yeah, it's so much fun.
If you watched it, thank you so much.
If not, I believe it might still be on the Anime Fest Dallas
Twitch channel.
Metal Gear Scholar.
But today, how do I get to it, actually?
Wait, I think it's under here.
Edit map?
No, no.
How do I go to the maps?
Isn't there play?
Oh, I found it!
I found it!
Today I would like to play some custom maps.
And, um, you know, I kind of... Sorry, I'm super brain
empty, you guys.
I'm so...
I'm not burnt out.
I think I'm just overworked a little bit.
Um, and I feel like, I feel bad because I'm like, oh gosh,
I'm going to be brain empty and just playing balloons every
day.
But, um, sorry, sorry for monkey brain.
You guys, I have something to tell you.
I have something to tell you.
In August, okay, so I go to Otakathon and...
And then like, just a couple days later, I fly to Japan, and
I'm gonna be in Japan for over a month.
It somehow turned into that.
So basically, I had made plans with Matara.
And then something else came up.
And I thought it was a good opportunity.
So I didn't say no.
But I'll have all my stuff.
I'll still be streaming.
I will.
Attempting schedules and everything.
I'll still be streaming.
I'm so sorry that my schedules have been.
So.
Not great recently.
But after September, after I get back, things will be more
normal.
I've said no to things.
But I've also said yes to things.
Congratulations on your honeymoon in Japan.
With who?
Ayami?
That's great to meet you yesterday.
I hope my sister's keychain plush made it to you without a
joke.
Thank you!
My gosh, I can't wait to get it.
They said they were going to send it to me.
So yeah, I will get it.
I will get it.
I wish I could go to Europe some day travels to Japan for
the 50th time this year.
It's not my fault!
It's not my fault.
Because, uh...
Um...
It's really just like...
Like I said, the one thing.
that I got asked to do.
And then, Matara and I weren't even gonna...
I wasn't even gonna do the second trip to Japan.
It's because Matara gave me COVID and so we couldn't do
anything that we wanted to!
Before!
Stop beating yourself up.
It's no fun to bully somebody who bullies himself.
Oh.
You still bully me.
P.S.
Short and stanky.
You still bully me.
I'm from Texas but I'm sorry I couldn't go to do the work,
boss.
What?
That's totally fine, Vixie!
Oh my gosh.
But, um, yeah.
So, it's gonna be a busy month for me.
It already was.
This month.
But I'm having fun.
Let's see what the newest maps are.
Sometimes you get some really funny maps in here.
Sometimes you get some really crazy...
Oh, wait, I can show you my favorites.
Here's my favorite maps.
we have the monkey ice god we have the edelwood ticket which
isn't that edelwood isn't that from over the garden wall we
have five knights of freddies we have why are you in my
swamp we have maxwell the cat we have this really awesome
interstellar one My head's kind of big.
Interstellar.
And then Aqua.
Aqua from Konosuba.
Yeah.
COVID-9, you got cute vids.
Maxwell or Riot?
It's so awesome, right?
Just make sure you get your rest.
brain frog is real i know i am worried about the brain frog
but i've also been planning some stuff as well um i've been
trying to be like okay if i if i have free day i do this so
yeah gonna leave her behind in economy class again she
wasn't even in economy class but also we're not flying
together this time i wonder if there's any mint ones mint
Oh, mint monkey.
What about minto?
I have a question as a new wisp.
I've been trying to figure this out for a good while.
What is that big old spike on the top of your head?
Is it part of the maid outfit or is it a hat?
What is it?
Let me see if I can pull up a picture.
it's actually it's actually a ghost thing
it's called a and it's something you'll often see ghosts
wearing here here here here like this here here that's such
a great question also thanks for being here new wisp
everybody be nice to the new wisp see see but mine is just
kind of of off-centered a little bit.
It's her horn because she's horny.
It's not wrong, but it's also not the case here.
I thought it was a dunce cap!
A dunce cap!
I'll tell you, I have an IQ of 181!
I have an IQ of 187!
I just gained 5...
6 IQ points just now.
I, I, my IQ, my IQ is older than your dog.
Your grandma and their ages combined.
My IQ is higher than your family bloodline.
Dunscap.
Dunscap, they said the dunscap.
But yeah, it's called the Hittai Cakushi.
Or a ghost triangle.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, though.
These look so good.
I do remember seeing them on Twitter.
But thank you for uploading them.
Ghost triangle.
Ghost horn.
Gold.
Let's, uh, you know what?
Let's do the Minto maps.
I have another meet and greet later on so uh what time is
that let me confirm
uh um let me see where's the where's my schedule wait
there's my schedule I have another one and I don't lot of
hours 8 30 cst am I gonna see you there again rice not
I was so shocked.
The meet and greets were, like, in front of everybody.
Let him live.
No.
Difficulty.
What's medium?
Oh, yeah.
We'll do medium.
We were shocked, too.
I know.
You didn't know either?
No.
I had no idea.
It was my first time that it was, like, a...
public meet and greet like that.
It was so crazy.
But everyone was so funny.
Even the person that showed me like fetish art of my, that
they commissioned.
They were like, do you want to see some art I commissioned
of you?
And I was like, yeah.
And they showed me a picture and I was like, oh, so cute.
And I was like, why am I holding a frying pan?
And then he was like, do you want to
more risky I was like yeah and then he showed it to me I was
like oh I get why I have a frying pan it
was a chubby minto I was like huh oh my god was it because
you were cooking more ways than one probably I was like oh
my god no This is...
Sometimes...
I think we're too comfortable with each other.
Where can I put... Oh, I can't in my hair.
Oh, but sometimes in my hair.
Oh, wait, this is the pathway, right?
Wow, there's so much space!
Oh, I can't in the flowers.
Or on my sleeves.
here.
Okay, let's just do let's, we gotta see what way is the
I'm gonna put Sada okay, this might be stupid.
I'm gonna put Sada at the end so we can see what the pathway
is.
We can always move her.
Here they go!
Around my face!
They're framing me!
Should this be a, no, I feel like with the Ice Monkey only
challenge, we could have, uh, what's the word?
We'll do the Ice Monkey god what oh god uh gonna make my
shrink myself a little bit we'll do the ice monkey god um
map and we'll do only ice monkeys wait what can be my nose
why didn't you give me a nose
it's missing become
your own nose this this can be my nose There's a spot for
0-0 Ice Monkey in the center of the heart.
Also, all the blue is water.
We could put Ice Monkey in the center of the heart?
No way.
Oh!
What a great map, Ashen!
Thank you!
Uh-oh.
Come on.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
No!
They're getting through!
Handle it.
Miss Melchan!
Thanks for the gift!
Thank you!
Two!
Uh-oh.
Be fast.
Be swift.
But yeah, the con has been a lot of fun so far.
I had a first panel.
That one was also streamed with, uh, um, with two other, uh,
two other VTubers.
And, um,
Oh my god.
With Mika and Zane and they put together a PowerPoint or
like a Guess the Monster thing for me.
Oh wait, so these are water.
Oh nice.
Is this water too?
Oh wow, it's all water.
I want to make my own map.
You have to pay for it.
Minto your Godot senses.
Godot moment.
What can I say?
When I say that I love someone or something...
It's true love.
Is this a... Oh, here.
I'm trying to... How can I...
Maybe I should make the plane my nose.
The hadn't been sound was crazy.
It was just because it was a shadow person.
But it ended up being...
even crazier than I expected.
I didn't think I was right.
Like how you love Snake.
Yeah.
Hee hee hee sexy soup.
For those... Oh my gosh.
Oh no!
Sada, what are you doing?
We're gonna... Oh, good, good, good.
Here we go.
My nose.
I look like a piggy.
Come on, thanks.
I love Chibimento so much.
I think it's the Garfield-like uninterested expression in
your eyes.
I hate Mondays.
You should have said your hitae kakushi was like a horn.
Like Venom Snake's horn grows more the...
grows the more you make wisps cry.
Oinky doink.
My brain is so empty today.
I think also I had to take some like medicine.
and I still am hung over from the met it's like a it's like
an allergy medicine you know when you take an allergy
medicine and it makes your brain fog so much the Texan air I
noticed nose is sideways nose it's fine this way sticks with
me the whole next day yeah I know me too it's so like oh the
anihistamines eight mondays love lasagna simple a's zyle
welcome to membership thank you it was prescribed
anihistamines for sleeping tablets one time yeah I've been
given they gave one time they gave me medicine that was like
a daily medicine that was anihistamines I was like I can't
take this it was okay I was just say it was an anti-anxiety
it was anti-anxiety meds and i was like i'm gonna be i'm
gonna be more anxious because i'm tired because i can't wake
up oh lucky thanks for the tag gifted but yeah ever since i
took the medicine that the benadryl i've been like my brain
can't wake up
take your ghost meds all right let's see Let's do, uh, which
ones?
Yeah, Flying Fortress.
I love never miss targeting.
Yeah!
Never miss, never miss, never miss!
Oh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Uh-oh.
Guys, I think we're in trouble.
Come on!
Keep popping!
Guys, we're already... We've lost so many lives.
Let's take my anxiety meds before, Ben.
But even still, like, the next day it just makes me be
like...
That's why I'm monkey brain right now.
Bust those bloons.
Come on.
Monkey brain.
Minto map doesn't play around.
Oh!
You know what?
Let's, uh...
Wait, where does it start?
Shoot.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Okay, we're good.
Yeah, start squishing.
Start squishing those bigger globs.
New Generation Anihistamies are safer.
Benadryl hits really hard and ain't supposed to be great on
the daily.
Oh, I don't take it daily.
I took it...
I took it two days ago.
And I'm still feeling it.
I'm like, whoa.
Uh-oh.
We're losing more stuff, you guys.
in trouble.
I think we might be in trouble.
This map is pretty hard with its short path.
Why'd you gotta make it so difficult?
How'd you draw everything?
It's literally...
It's literally me.
Yeah!
yeah, but yeah, but yeah, but, yeah, but yeah, but...
It's me if I had a tan.
Minto goes to the beach.
Fake.
Oh my god.
Go Sada, go!
Go Sada!
Oh, she's faster now!
She's faster now.
She's leveled up.
Yes!
So is Ice Monkey.
He's faster now.
Come on.
Nice.
Tan lines on Mint Artist, please.
Summer's got you.
thinking summer brained.
Is that Mume?
Thank you for the tan gifted.
Thank you so much.
I don't never, you know, oh shoot.
Uh oh.
Oh wait.
We have Sawata.
She's great.
I, even when I would go out a lot and outside, I never got
tan lines or anything.
I am a I'm a ghost that burns My ectoplasm burns.
I do not tan.
So it's...
So it's hard for me to...
Because you're a ghost.
Yeah.
I don't... I don't tan though.
But it's kind of sad, right?
Like...
Okay.
Okay, we're so close.
Come on, come on, Sada.
Don't let them pass.
Handle it.
She reflects all the beams.
Come on!
Once we have the never miss, we'll be so good.
Yeah!
Oh yeah!
Not even a farmer's tan.
You know how like some people, if they drive, they get like
a driver's tan?
Like just the left side of their...
Or I guess depends on where you drive.
If you drive on the left side or the right side.
My favorite game, Balloon... Balloon Teddy 6.
Is that related to Ben 10?
Uh-oh.
Wait.
I need something.
I need Scissors 61.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
You.
No!
I can't be I am out.
Oh, you sawed his ability.
What does this do?
Oh, neat.
I have to pay for them.
Which one would you want, Ashen?
You want right...
Can I give...
35% of any accolade purchase goes directly to the registered
player.
You can make money off of this?
Time to quit my job.
Why?
Okay.
Ashen off stream, I'm gonna give you...
I'm gonna give you...
Dancing Monkey.
I'm gonna give you RGB Monkey.
I'm gonna give it up to you.
Rip Bozo.
Shut up.
Shut up to you.
I can't believe I lost.
I mean, I can.
I wasn't very playing.
I wasn't playing very well.
But let's try the next one.
This one.
This
one.
It looks like I'm eating leaves.
Is this all water?
Let's see.
Oh, it is!
Oh, there's plenty of water on this map.
Not, is this one?
I like the music in this one.
Speaking of time, Minto Art, don't forget to use Boomer for
10% off your gamer subs order.
Let's give Minto her own wife a go.
Thank you!
So we have Bloom's B-Tuber super chat to you.
but speaking of the gamer subs i do have to still um i i was
thinking maybe um instead of using a google form uh my
friend actually linked me to a website that might be better
because i feel like a google form i was thinking like i was
thinking i was like if some people retweet the form you know
and then it like goes outside of my sphere and then people
are just like oh free 100 coupon I'll take it yeah for the
giveaway giveaway yeah yeah yeah so I was just like I want
to give it to one of you guys I don't want to give it to
some randos so um I'm gonna try the uh the website it's one
of those things where it's just like follow the mint phantom
on Twitter and subscribe to her channel and one of those but
I'm not gonna make it so like egregious where it's like tell
your grandma Share on Facebook, you know, so...
Gleam?
What's Gleam?
No, the one my friend sent me was...
Something else.
Tell grandma.
Retweet all of Minto's tweets for one entry.
yeah those send to five friends yeah yeah i don't want to do
all of that so i told my rabbit about you thank you all
right we're gonna put soda do you think i could put soda
where do i go where does it where does the balloons go i
guess we'll find out music in this one is so fun
Rabbits know a lot of critters, too.
I showed my dog your snake eater short.
He loved it.
I'm honored.
Ta-da, ta-da, ta-da, ta-da.
Let's see.
Let's also do...
Let's put him here.
He's our backup defense.
How did your panel go mint?
That was fun.
It was so much fun.
It goes from the dotted lines, then down your shoulder.
So like...
Oh!
Well, we'll see.
Here we go.
Oh!
I should have put that boat there.
What's wrong with me?
Let's put him here.
Long range!
Around my huge head.
It's for holding all my secrets!
Oh yeah, Mermonkey, I have seen Mermonkey.
I'm excited because Mermonkey looks like...
It looks like Mermonkey can go on land and on sea!
That's huge!
That's... that's big news!
all right then keep your secrets
okay we're gonna oh whoops my bad I don't know why press
that on accident um we're gonna work with these guys I want
to go with the middle the middle the middle barbed darts
once we get this we can pierce the I think the next one can
pierce the lead yeah yeah the lead and the the steely ones,
right?
I can really put Ice Monkey in your heart.
I wish there was a good place for Ice Monkey on this map.
Maybe my eyes.
Oh, that's not Ice Monkey.
Oh, I can't afford Ice Monkey.
There we go.
You could be kissing him.
The eyes are water.
Brick, you made this one, didn't you?
Kissing ice monkey.
Thank you for being so easy to show how awesome vtubers are.
I just showed my normie friends your rendition of break
stuff.
They love it.
Really?
Oh my god.
What just happened?
Oh, I didn't mean to click that.
I meant to...
Oh my gosh, I meant to click this guy.
Oh.
people love your break stuff I get so embarrassed I guess I
seriously I can't even Like watch I can't listen to myself
back about it Can't carry a Before watching Mint I was a
believer in laws Like Murphy's Law where anything that can
go wrong Will go wrong Since I discovered Mint my life Has
changed for the better Now I only believe in Cole's Law
Which is Shred and cabbage and creepy chest
That was actually so good!
It caught me...
It caught me so off guard.
Oh my...
That one was so funny.
That one was so good, Kinky!
Cold Sloth!
Oh wow, I really like that one.
Let's do ballistic missiles.
Now I get...
Yeah, Kohl'slaw!
It's shredded cabbage and creamy dressing!
But it's Kohl's...
Lua!
Damn, I just got it.
Glitchface, your friend told me that you wanted to be at the
con, but you couldn't make it.
Thanks for explaining.
You know what, I also don't really like Kohl's Law that
much, I'll be honest.
I'm not a hater.
But I don't like Kohl's Law that much.
It's okay, you know.
Where do you think I can put...
Hmm.
Let's put Druid Monkey.
Let's put him over here.
So, wait.
Where do they go again?
Oh, shoot.
I think I'm too good at the game.
I can't tell what the path is.
It's this way, right?
It goes up and around down my shoulder.
I think?
Some recipes are better than others.
I was introduced to using Greek yogurt for making coleslaw.
Well, I think it's also...
I don't like raw cabbage at all.
I hate raw cabbage.
I love...
I will eat cooked cabbage for days.
But raw cabbage, I really dislike.
Every time I've eaten coleslaw, it's had five pounds of
sugar.
sugar and it's gross.
Ew.
Sourcrow?
I don't think I've ever had it.
She hates raw cabbage.
I do!
Just don't use raw cabbage then.
But isn't that like the point of coalslaw?
Mint slaw.
She hates all her cabbage viewers.
Raise your hand if you're a cabbage viewer i'll personally
apologize maybe i can put uh him here put him here put him
here pal and oh here maybe and then um put him here and then
and then um i can have will the farms fit oh i don't think
Hmm.
Hold on, let's see how it works.
If I can fit like, oh, guys.
Oh, oh, oh.
I thought I broke the game.
Good morning, Minta.
I hope you're doing great today.
You too, Magister.
The Cabbage Warriors.
I saw not a single hand.
I think you guys are lying.
I'm just kidding.
What is this part that makes it so I can't build on it, I
wonder?
Hmm.
Do I want to keep him here or not?
Oh, we also need a plain monkey.
A plain monkey.
I'm going to put plain monkey here.
Rapid fire.
Okay, here we go.
Well we got plain monkey, but when are we getting plantain
monkey?
We're all cabbages near the Cabbage Man from Avatar the
Last, Airbender.
My cabbages!
I'm gonna sell him.
Bye!
This map looks like the VTuber Minto Minto.
I don't see the resemblance.
Whatever happened to the cabbage guy.
Was he okay?
Who?
Don't who me!
Oh, I think we got it.
Nice.
Oh, yeah, here we go, baby.
Oh, yeah!
I think we're good for a minute.
Actually, hold on.
I want to do this.
Um, Do you think it'll reach?
Okay, you know what?
Hmm.
I don't think it'll reach.
Oh, no!
I wanted to get both of them, but I don't think it'll reach.
Bigger.
No!
Hmm.
He made a company call.
cabbage core they build automobiles we have
enough for a nice monkey yeah we do
i'll decide what i want to do after a few more
i love never miss playing look at that so awesome ghost
monkey win yeah ghost monkey win i mean we have necromancer
monkey but it's not the same second village to make the
first village longer wait can i do that how do you do that
how would it this one monkey city increases influence this
one right just overlap the zones okay
we'll do here what I keep accidentally pressing and then
breaking the game.
Um...
Guys?
Yippee!
It worked!
I didn't know that!
Oh my god!
Uh-oh.
Ah!
Okay, we're not quite Moab ready.
Good to know.
Secret monkey tech.
We'll make everybody faster at least.
Yeah, that was pretty bad.
That wasn't great.
Monkey farm.
I do need a monkey farm.
I need monkey everything.
I'm trying to save up money.
Monkey money.
Corvus is kind of a ghost monkey, but the cool part is that
he commands a whisk.
Who's Corvus?
You're just making people up.
Micromanagement heavy though.
Oh, I forgot I also have this.
Use it for the next, uh...
Let's see.
Let's do the Moab glue.
So if we get another Moab, it should be real slow.
Four, four, four, four!
We were at four, four, four!
Four, four, money!
Spooky!
Where's Ice Monkey?
He's on vacation.
Glue Gunner?
Glue Gunner's pretty good.
I think Glue Gunner's a little underrated.
As you can see, like it makes it really...
They really slow down a lot.
Where should I put him?
I could put him like See I'm just like I want him close to
some To some monkey Wait It goes along the dotted line right
If I put him here He should still reach some Some farms then
I think Hmm Also very good with Sada Yeah just above Sada
But it won't reach over up here right It goes through my
hair this hair.
If there's here, this would be good.
Oh my god.
Oh, that was close.
Hmm.
Good job, everybody.
I want to make money.
I actually use Ice Monkey more than Glue Gunner.
Ice Monkey will never work a day in his life.
Except he has all this experience.
It has popped like five alludes.
Works like, but coming home to Minto stream.
Outsu!
Outsu, Outsu, Outsu.
Free loader.
Kind of.
I didn't say it, though.
You did.
Oh, shoot.
It's the Moab.
Oh, my God.
Nice.
Come on, Saurah.
Handle it.
oh nice everybody nice do i want to up you know what i will
upgrade this one upgrade that one and then we make more
money don't let ice monkeys hands get dirty everybody hates
dirty ice that's the worst it gets so disgusting i was about
to i was about to unironically i was about to start like
speaking like that one guy in Star Wars that's just like I
hate sand it's coarse I was gonna be like I hate dirty eyes
it's gross it's dirty it's coarse I was about to
unironically sound like that guy Anakin yeah nice all right
let's get you know what you go here actually
Here.
Then we can start...
I wonder if it'll reach.
I think so.
If I put one here...
No!
Doesn't fit.
Turned boiled pasta water into ice cubes to serve to guests
that you don't like.
Ew!
Money, money, money!
Wait, I think his, uh...
Generates, oh...
Wait, Generate...
I thought his range increased.
I do that with rubbing alcohol.
That doesn't sound legal.
I'll be honest.
Oh, why did I do that?
I did not mean to do that.
That doesn't sound like...
Doesn't sound very good.
Doesn't sound very legal.
I'll be honest.
But I've always, I know, I've always wanted to try like
doing the ice, the chocolate milk ice cubes and stuff like
that.
That sounds good.
I do it with cyanide.
I also think that's not legal.
Oh my gosh, we're almost there.
or coffee coffee ice cubes yes oh my god in just one shot
i'll also give you a dancing monkey
don't worry brick i'll give you a dancing monkey too
cold brew ice cubes would totally work yeah why use frozen
coffee or chocolate milk when you could Use ice cream.
Just ice.
But ice cream, it doesn't.
The ice cream doesn't become like a.
It doesn't become like a Kulu-Bub.
It's a different drink.
Oh no, the reinforced ones.
Wait, what did I...
It's this guy, right?
He's our reinforcement.
Yeah, yeah.
He shatters them shows.
We're going to put you...
we're gonna put you right right we're gonna stick you right
we're gonna you're gonna go right in we're gonna have you
right we're gonna stick you right right we're gonna you're
gonna go right over in there you're gonna stick right in
there still right there there
oh my god
I was scared for a second
Sorry you didn't take that pill.
With the Benadryl.
No, I'm okay.
I'm okay!
Yeah.
Whoa.
I feel like I should have gotten more money from that.
Nice.
I'm just gonna keep going.
I'm just gonna keep on going.
Wait, how much?
How much do you have?
22.
Oh, we're not going to get into the blue incineration.
That's kind of sad.
The big one.
Increases Bernie stuff.
Damage.
Seems like a good couple.
Power couple.
No farms?
Nah, this is, uh...
I'm...
This is...
I don't want to be in...
This is, uh...
This is the run where I...
I don't sell myself.
You know?
We're just doing it.
Oh, natural.
It's a big farm.
I'm in poor mood.
Yeah.
Get it?
I'm trying to save up so we can get...
Maybe Spectre.
We're almost there.
We'll get there.
Oh, but maybe I want Spirit of the Force.
Hmm.
Um, I'll decide.
But Spectre is sooner than this one.
Monkey Paragon's win.
That's the, that's the, like, the triplets, right?
I think we'll do Spectre.
Monkey Paragon.
Yeah, I gotta...
Oh my gosh, wait, I think I need to finish Metal Gear Solid
2.
And Eternal Darkness.
Oh my gosh, before I leave for Japan!
Oh no!
And then I'll play 3 once I get home.
Is this a monkey XP grinding stream?
It's a monkey stream!
Oh, that was so fast.
Next, we'll go for this guy.
Metal Gear Enduring Streamlines, go!
Hell yeah.
I wouldn't say we're close to the end of MGS2.
I think we're, like, halfway there.
But if I'm, like, strong next time, I might be able to get
it through it.
One or two more.
For sure.
Yay!
Thanks for three months.
At the end, it does have a lot of cutting, you're right.
Nice.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
Look at him.
Go!
What's the other plane?
The other one that's pretty good.
Oh, Sky Shredder.
Oh, wait, I have all of them unlocked.
See, I need more.
I need more XP.
I only have 14,000.
Skip the cutscenes!
Never!
It's a lot grinding for paragons.
Yeah.
And I don't use anything like the...
like the special stuff that they...
the monkey knowledges and things like that.
I'm un- unknowledged.
We're close to...
How much...
You were at 22?
You're still at 22.
Okay, that's fine.
Let's get to the 35,000.
Or 29,000.
I don't know.
Which one ever.
Whichever yet.
Nice.
Even though your IQ is so high.
That's why it's so high.
I don't need to rely on cheats.
I don't need to rely on, you know, these...
simple, these simple methods.
Mint is the one who finally got me into PTD6.
What do you mean finally?
How long have you been waiting to play this game?
This one will also generate more money and more lives.
I love Spirit of the Forest.
Might be my favorite.
My favorite thing.
Nice!
Now we can see the pathway!
That's the real reason I got it.
Oh.
A little more.
Yep.
Nice.
Now we know the real pathway.
Basically wanted to wait for a sale.
I think it was on sale during the steam sale, wasn't it?
Maybe I should do the banana farms over here and have it
absorb them.
Like so.
Right?
Hmm.
Double mint.
crown now when did the DDTs come and 90 right I'm
scared I'm scared for those 90 yeah okay oh might be good to
have this guy kind of facing down we could start working on
our mega laser hmm which way do we want the laser hmm like
if i go here it'll be like phew hmm also ships this is all
this is all this is all water baby wait oh i think because
of my sleeve
we can own this map yeah you can go play this map yourself
just search minto cute made thank you go sweat probably
actually sweaty sweaty sweaty sweaty sweaty here we'll get
this guy we'll put him like right here and we'll do we'll do
we'll do the pirate Lord yeah wait and the double shot
Oh, I heard a DDT.
Oh.
We're so good.
We are so good.
We're going to make it all the way, everybody.
I believe.
We're going to make it all the way.
Grape shot.
Don't jinx it.
What if I just casually got to 200?
100, like on just a one-off stream, where I was just like,
yeah, I'm just playing bloons because I'm, you know, yeah,
I'm just playing bloons just to, you know, hang out and play
a game.
I'm just playing bloons.
What about you?
We need 29,000.
You too.
The super glue.
You know what?
Let's do the super glue.
Okay.
Autopilot gaming.
It does make me really relaxed, though, when I play this
game.
And what I like is I can just kind of take a break in
between, like, rounds.
I can be like, ah, I've got to go do something.
And I'll leave and, like, just do it.
It's kind of awesome.
I did a round on the previous Minto map and died of 1.99!
No way!
What happened?
basically cookie clicker there's a little more thought oh I
haven't checked on my cookies in a while
the BAD might be trouble yeah I think so too
it's okay we're gonna upgrade we still have a few upgrades
to do like these two can still upgrade and this one can
still upgrade so we're focusing on focusing on upgrading
Which one do I want to do first?
We'll get this guy.
What does it do anyway?
Oh yeah!
Whenever Moab spawns, it like does a big old...
Yeah,
we're upgrading.
Don't worry, we're upgrading!
Oh!
Don't be here.
Uh-oh.
What?
What went past?
Huh?
I didn't even see anything!
Did he tease?
I didn't even see them!
I didn't even see them at all!
Steely craze keeps giving you a little...
I think Steely craze is flirting with you.
Casually gets around 200.
Okay, okay.
okay okay I see you
I will also give you one dancing RGB monkey off stream
though off stream but I'll give you a monkey who is jelly
craze I think did they give this one too who gave it to you
who gave this need some paragons to reach level 200 no i
believe i believe we can go without it i i know oh wait i
know we can but guys it's time it's time for the moment
you've been waiting for one two ready ice monkey bee
wait can monkey i i have a question can monkey destroy ice
monkey destroy balloons or does ice monkey only just freeze
the balloons
yes the bottom path but what if i never make any money
there's damage okay all of them can pop okay okay so i'm
just gonna put them out What?
Uh oh.
Wait.
Ice Monkey.
This music is crazy.
Wait.
I don't think Ice Monkey can...
I don't think Ice Monkey can reach.
Wait, where did the...
I don't think Ice Monkey has...
To...
Wait!
Wait, they said they start over here!
Oh!
Oh, they start here and then leave here!
I managed to make it past round 200 without Paragon so I
believe he can do it.
Also, I did it on company time.
Let's go!
Go Ice Monkey!
Oh, he's slow.
Oh, Ice Monkey.
Oh, they circle multiple times.
Oh, Ice Monkey!
Ice Monkey, please!
I can't pop camel I think Uh oh, okay I guess we'll do ice
monkey plus village
Enhance freezing Tax faster, that's what we need Okay, buddy
Enhance Enhance ice monkey Oh, top path Okay, well we're
gonna have so many ice monkeys you guys Like We're gonna to
be able to do every oh every single path it's got a nice
crunch ice monkey don't just juggle you're losing lives uh
this one can freeze and pop whoa
oh super cold aura that slows balloons and freezes water
nearby That might be good, right?
I'm going to go for the bottom path, though.
For now.
Uh-oh.
Guys, we might run out of lives before we, uh...
Maybe I should have put Ice Monkey in a different spot.
But if we have to redo it, that's okay, too.
Because, um...
I just didn't know where the path was.
Yeah!
Good job, Ice Monkey!
0-25 is my way to go.
Oh my gosh.
Why are ice monkeys so expensive?
Oh come on, come on.
It's 425 and we're at 423.
This is so messed up.
Go ice monkey.
Okay, I'm gonna slow it down so we can make another ice
monkey.
Why can't I only put in some places and not others?
Oh my god, ice monkey.
Do something!
Nice.
Whoa, six shades.
You guys, the music is so fitting for this, honestly.
Yeah.
Get the ice monkey.
Whoa, nice, nice.
Oh my gosh, we're just bleeding.
You guys, we're bleeding lives.
Oh, no, wait.
That was the wrong monkey.
Too many ice monkey.
I can't keep up with ice monkey.
Okay.
That's okay, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
yeah yeah oh this is good this is good this is good yeah
yeah yeah nice nice oh this is good go go oh we only lost
one life that time not enough ice monkey shoots smaller ice
bombs increases pierce okay let's go for that but also how
do we want to go with this guy let's do that let's unlock
this okay maybe i should have had Ice Monkey gain more XP.
You guys, let's try and get to round 40.
Let's try and get through the map, okay?
That's what our goal will be.
That's what the goal will be.
Just get through the map.
Get through.
Get through the map.
Oh my god, I'm so poor.
I need more money!
Okay, nice.
Look, Working together, they're really working together.
Mice, ice, ice, ice, ice, ice.
Yeah!
Clap, monkey, clap!
Oh, oh, oh my God, oh my God.
Clap, clap, clap, clap!
Clap, clap!
Oh, shoot.
Okay, that's fine.
Keep going, keep going!
Clap, monkey, clap!
Deep freeze.
It's getting breezy in here.
It's getting breezy!
I like the sound they make.
It's really crunchy.
No juggling?
They juggle on their own time.
They juggle when they have time.
I wish though...
I put monkey over here, monkey here, you know?
I wish I could also put monkey out here.
We gotta get them all.
Maybe I just like spam monkey and...
here let's put monkey over here first monkey defense ain't
making it what are you talking about we're gonna make it go
see he's getting some oh the yellow ones we don't care about
those they can leave they're not invited it's the dark blue
water i'm actually not sure i think this is definitely water
um i can't tell until we make more money this guy can go
with um
tax faster we'll go with this one
kind of oh my god oh my god we've lost so many lives guys um
i don't know if we're gonna make it yeah this is all water
this is all water love the chill stream thanks It's so ice
over.
Come on, Ice Monkey!
Come on!
Clap!
Oh god!
Ice Monkey, Ice Monkey, Ice Monkey, Ice Monkey, Ice Monkey,
Ice Monkey, Ice Monkey!
Make more money!
Nice!
He's soloing!
Get popped!
Clap!
Get
popped!
Get- Yeah!
Okay, we need to increase our monkey.
Uh-oh.
Clap!
Get popped!
Yes!
Pop!
Oh gosh.
Uh-oh.
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
Someone is not doing their job!
So, it looks like my, like the ice monkey has like really
stupid googly eyes like this.
I'm ice monkey!
Clap, clap, clap, pop the monkey!
I've clapped the balloon!
Oh, it's so over.
The disrespect of that one red balloon.
Hold on, let's restart.
Let's restart.
we have we are 22 is the new 40.
we are we are we are stronger now i tried doing this with
just ice monkey and couldn't do it such i gave up because
one type of balloon that's why i failed
it's okay it's only three it's only three it's only three
next there
we go nice nice nice Yep.
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Sha, sha, sha.
Oh.
He was frozen, and then...
Then he wasn't.
Don't juggle out of time like this.
It's embarrassing.
Enhanced freeze.
Thanks for the laughs.
Thanks for laughing at me, Kru.
We're going all in.
Okay, I think I'm going to go all in on two monkeys.
I think having two is good.
I think any more, I won't have enough money.
You know what I mean?
I think I need to go on in on two monkeys.
For now.
Until we can hold our own.
You know?
You're in for a bad time once the white bloons show up.
But, but this one can...
One of them...
One of them will work, right?
One of them, one of these will be able to take care of it.
Right.
Look, we're already doing so much better than before.
Freeze, freeze, clap, clap.
Clap!
No!
Red balloon!
Get him!
Yeah!
I went against my...
We're gonna give this guy...
I don't know.
We're just gonna... He's our backup.
He's our backup monkey.
We're saving up for this one.
smaller ice bombs.
We're saving up.
Now he's looking down.
In disgust over how disappointed he is.
Oh my god.
Come on!
You can do it!
Next to that, like here in the In the crease of the I-
That's a good idea.
I'm going to sell him.
Put him here.
You're so right.
Top of the eye would be better.
Is it?
Every game we learn a new- Why aren't you doing anything?
Pop!
I'm saving up.
I'm saving up for the cryo- Okay.
So he's looking up.
Things are looking up from here.
This guy can't even reach.
There we go.
Goodness gracious.
What's this one?
Oh, let's do this.
I said I was saving up.
4-4-4!
Oh my god.
Ow!
It's so fast.
You're so slow.
Why are you so...
You can't even hit that guy.
Solid snake ice.
Fuck you.
Oh my god.
You're too slow.
Oh, he's going to get this guy, though.
Oh.
We're still at 169.
Eight.
Okay.
Maybe I should just restart them.
I want to see what this does.
Cryo cannon.
If we can even get there.
Oh.
Single red blue.
Okay.
Go, go, go.
It's always that one blue and I know, right?
Come on.
Oh, they're regenerating.
Everything is bad.
Everything sucks.
Here it is.
There it goes.
Wow, 48.
We're, like, close to it, so I just want to see what it
does.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Nice, everybody.
We're so close.
This round, this round.
We got this.
Speve, everybody.
Oh, dang it.
Okay, next.
Oh.
There we go.
Let's try it out.
Wait, are these the guys that...
Oh,
he can't even get all the yellow ones, though.
You're so slow.
He is kind of awesome.
Oh, here we go.
Guys.
I think this challenge is impossible.
I think this challenge is on easy difficulty.
what what are the white the white ones are they uh are you
feeling 22
what are the white balloons balloons count as i've never i
don't even think i've ever considered what they are the
white ones cannot be frozen free freeze immune oh immune to
ice that's why i never knew
This ice monkey map is probably made by an ice monkey hater.
I
never use ice monkey.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't even know if we would be able to afford.
I don't think we could afford it.
Like, I don't think we could afford.
an ice monkey getting as good as it did before and then also
you always use oh oh oh ice monkey look look like let's see
oh gosh a village is one thousand twenty and then in the
middle right
There's no way.
There's no way we'd get there in time with also upgrading a
monkey.
Oh no, is this challenge impossible?
No.
Is this challenge impossible?
Get a dart monkey.
That's not the point.
The challenge is ice monkey only.
Oh, no.
Snowstorm.
Freeze all regular balloons on Scream.
Briefly freezes.
Why zebra camo and slows moat?
Wow.
Let's try putting the ice monkey at the top.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I need the larger radius is 150.
Will I have enough?
Like here?
Yes.
Nice.
Okay.
Go!
Not a single life lost, baby!
Oh my god.
We're making it out of the ice age with this one.
Don't get your hopes up.
We're on round three and we still have 200 lives, everybody.
Huge, huge, huge.
Then we just get the deep freeze.
No!
Oh my god.
I like the crunchy sounds.
Me too.
Sounds really good.
Gonna start using Ice Monkey all the time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She's the master of only one element.
Three months for Ice Monkey!
I did!
Thank you!
Yeah.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, that's the good stuff.
That's
the...
It sounds like it's going through every crevice of my brain
wrinkles.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my gosh.
I wish I could make the clapping a little less loud, but...
Oh, yeah, go through my brain.
Crackle Yeah Ice Monkey ASMR Yeah Next Model Ice Monkey
Cosplay What are you talking about?
You have brain wrinkles?
Oh sorry I know that's a foreign concept to you Yeah most
brains Hold on I'll say this really slowly for you Kason
Brains think brain think thinking wrinkles no wrinkle no
think you no wrinkle you monkey brain you think like monkey
but mint really wrinkly no sunscreen ever no care only
wrinkle
hag monkey hag monkey hag monkey hag monkey no thank I mean
only say wait only wrinkles hag monkey oh my gosh we lost we
lost one boys we lost one but
I don't think we're gonna make enough money in time though
have you used any of your knowledge points you could make
ice monkeys stronger if you wanted to or other monkeys I
haven't used a single monkey point.
What is this map?
It's Ice Monkey Map, baby!
We're not gonna make enough money for a monkey, but I'll do
my best to I'm making a four-mong- Your brain is smooth.
No, your- you are brain is smooth.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
We've only lost a little bit of lives, but that's okay.
I think you need another ice monkey if we won't have any
money.
It'll cost so much to get zero-zero- wait.
It would cost much less to get zero-fourth.
Ice then to get 0, 3, I...
Oh, wait.
What's 0, 4?
Wait.
I can't even get the 4, though.
I don't have enough EXP!
I don't have enough.
Bold words come here when the ghost who said the difference
between 181 and 187 is 5 at the beginning of the stream.
I!
You're making fun of my discalcula!
I have a learning disability!
You're gonna make some fun of someone with a learning
disability?
Mint color for mint, okay?
Yippee!
Yeah, we're gonna have to train Ice Monkey to redo.
I think we're gonna have to do a...
We're gonna have to do like a revenge for this.
We're gonna have to revenge.
See, yellow's just flying.
Don't look at them.
Yellow's a horrible color.
2000.
It's impossible.
It's really impossible.
What so then?
What is black balloons?
What are they immune to?
Green is not a creative color.
What are you talking about?
There's like only three green VTubers.
Okay.
Oh, explosions.
Oh my gosh.
Here it is.
My demise.
There we go.
Bye.
Poop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Oh.
Oh, yo, Super Chat.
Ah!
Man.
Oh, well.
Monkey money!
Wait, I want to get to the...
Where's the...
Oh.
I have 33 monkey points.
Yo, you can't see because chat's blocking it.
I have 33 of them.
Wait.
Oh, well, I haven't used any of them.
I was like, enable monkey knowledge, but I don't use it.
I could try Corvus.
Where's that guy?
Which one is?
him them oh yeah i don't have enough money i don't have
enough look at is this you is that you you're like oh monkey
is that you
literally me whoa he's got venom's hand
he stole your color oh wait what the little wisp guy I mean
basically all ghosts are either a shade of green or blue
it's like ghosts lore everybody every ghost has to be green
or blue that's just the way wait so is he a ghost a spirit
Walker Corvus works well on the front line weakening nearby
balloons to harvest mana and challenge powerful energies
through his spirit companion.
Or white.
Oh, yeah, white's fine too.
White's also good.
Oh, purple?
Purple's also fine.
Because Gengar, you know.
Luigi's Mansion is fiction.
Those are all paid actors.
Luigi's Mansion doesn't count.
Luigi is a fraud.
He's a big old phony.
He's just like, oh, I'm a ghost hunter.
No, he's not.
Those guys are literally there to be sucked up into a
vacuum.
Why do you hate Luigi?
Because I don't hate Luigi.
I just hate that he's a phony.
Green envy.
What about Ghostbusters?
Aren't those guys green?
Poor Luigi.
Mint a Wario fan?
I'm a Waluigi fan.
Maybe that's why I'm a Luigi hater.
I'm like, Waluigi.
I like why Luigi?
He's the correct answer.
Oh, that's worse.
How is that worse?
Why Luigi?
Or Luigi's just like a little weeny.
He's just like, Oh, brother.
Mama Mia.
And Mario, Mario is fine.
I hate, actually, I hate Mario.
I hate Mario.
Hi, that guy.
Mario can...
Mario can get stuck in a pipe.
Okay Bowser.
Yeah!
Yeah, Bowser!
My name is Mario?
Is it actually?
is it actually
cake boo confirmed yeah I love cake boo I love boo what is
your favorite monkey hero and why is it Sada in this skin
I'm gonna need some coffee hold on I'm gonna have a snack
no this is the chocolate one i want a peanut butter no wait
guys i gotta go get a peanut butter bar give me a second i
have a chocolate bar but i want a peanut butter bar give me
one second give me one second i'm gonna run and grab it it's
in my kitchen it's in my kitchen i'll be Give me one second.
Give me one second.
Pat thirsty.
One second.
I also got a cookie sando.
Yeah.
Tokyo banana.
Cookie sando.
It says cookie sando.
I'm going to try this.
I don't think I've had this yet.
Whoa.
It's just got a big old slice of...
Smells like banana and cookie.
Exactly as advertised.
Men, eat peanut butter.
No!
You can't make me!
But I do have a peanut butter bar.
Mmm, yum, yum.
Peanut butter is made for monkeys.
Visit a Nature Valley sweet and salty chewy nut butter.
No, it's a
It's a A gamer sub Sussbar
What do you do over Scooby Snack?
He was called Boomer.
Why do you sound so upset?
Because you guys will judge me!
Was it free?
Yeah.
Literally feeding this girl.
They're feeding me.
It's a sustainable nutritious food bar.
And it's peanut butter.
It's flavored.
And it was free.
Peanut butter!
And it's peanut butter and free.
How can I say no?
Free for free?
Food tastes better.
Shut up, Murphy.
Why is me being goofy have to do with starving?
Yeah, free food!
My only thing about this bar is it's like, it tastes like
the peanut butter.
The peanut butter that's like Japanese peanut butter, which
is just for some reason very sweet.
Let's um And I don't really like sweet peanut butter
Isn't Japanese mayo sweet as well?
It can be, yeah They like the bread is sweet The peanut
butter is sweet I don't want so much sweet all the time
Which is so funny because people are like Oh Japanese food
is like not sweet It's so like You know, it's so bland But
I'm like no, it's sweet How did I get to the...
Was it this?
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Let's look up the most liked.
Some of these are like serious...
This one is so funny.
It's so funny.
But some of these are like real art.
Look at jungly wongly.
What the hell?
Nothing gets past my axe, boy.
My wish order is shipping route.
Juggly, wungly.
Inception.
Vaporeon's garden.
Chronicle would like that one.
Among us, among us!
Mega Man's map.
Oh, wait.
That's not actual Mega Man.
Okay.
Oh, there's Maxwell.
I like this one already.
Some of these are so awesome.
Bloons?
Blonds if it was good.
First monkey shooter.
Plants versus bloons!
Shot.
Ah.
Oh my god!
No way!
Wait, what?
How does this work?
Huh?
I'm just gonna put it right here.
I don't know where they're gonna come from.
They're from all over!
Oh.
There's a monkey on your lawn.
There's sunflower.
I'm done with this one.
Go home.
That one seems hard.
There's another one!
What the hell?
They're made by two different people.
Plants vs.
Zombies.
Pool Day!
You think he'd be able to reach everyone?
He might be able to.
Four paths now.
Look, they come over.
This is so genius!
What?
What the hell?
This is just so...
It just is so...
So good, so well made!
Let's try to fight...
Oh wait.
Maybe like right here.
Let's see if it works.
Go, go!
Nice.
His reach.
Because
I think I realize what this stream has made me realize.
I think I need a break from balloons.
I feel like I'm...
I'm like, oh yeah, bloons.
Yeah, I played it.
Okay.
I think I'm like, I think I'm not, I think I'm like kind of,
I'm bloonsed out a little bit.
No such thing.
Yeah, I'm bloonsed out.
Plants versus zombies next stream.
Seeing this, I was just like more excited about the plants
versus zombies than the bloons.
But I'm really curious how this one gets with like the Moab.
Where do they, what?
come out and stuff.
I'm so curious how it'll work.
We'll keep playing.
We'll keep playing for now.
We'll keep trying it for now.
Four moabs.
Oh my.
But you get like a ton of money from this though, right?
Like there's so many here.
Let's for this guy.
Let's go with the pirate.
Oh.
Well, I spent all my money.
Never mind.
This guy will go for the top one.
I just got here and you're already tired of it.
I'm sorry!
Here is where I'm gonna put an airplane when I can afford
it.
Same amount of balloons, just different tracks.
Seriously?
Okay.
It is the same amount though.
It looks like so much more.
Is this actually how many balloons I've been shooting this
whole time?
That's crazy.
My little monkeys are so powerful.
Look at him, guys.
Don't forget the sunflower.
Yeah, the sunflower will bring us more money.
Each lane houses a quarter of the blue in each round.
So it would be only one Moab on the first lane.
Oh, place in the editor.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, because these new custom maps are pretty recent.
So I don't know so much about them yet.
Let's do...
Let's do double shot.
We'll just keep upgrading this guy.
I want to...
I want to see how it looks.
Look at all these zombies!
It would be fun if I had like a...
You know how like they make skins for the bloons?
It would be fun if I like...
Had one that made it like kind of...
Dead looking.
Chew!
No, that is not Mega Man.
Dear Mint, I hope this message finds you well.
By the time this don't-o alert appeared, I found the Tuturu
gacha.
I'm asleep.
Good night!
Oh, I thought I lost a life, but I didn't.
I think it...
Oh, yes, I did.
I think I lost a sum.
Whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Easy, easy, easy.
Yes.
Plants versus zombies map.
I know, right?
You guys, the tuturu is a lie.
I don't know where that lie came from.
Like, I don't know where that rumor started.
It's so weird.
But, um...
You know.
It's so weird.
How that started.
And, oh my god, we're losing lives.
From me!
Oh, I can't put the plane here.
What can I put here?
Little dart monkey.
From me!
How dare you!
How dare you say that?
I missed the tuturula.
I couldn't have been you.
Yeah, it wasn't me.
That was not me.
I can tell you that with full confidence.
Oh my gosh, I can even put monkeys out here?
What?
That's crazy.
Wait.
The monkeys can go anywhere.
Look at he's outside of bounds.
Warrior monkey.
Rolling for mint noise.
Nice monkey, why aren't you doing anything?
Handle it.
Uh-oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I instinctually said...
Hello, chat.
Hello.
He is watching.
Yeah, he is.
He's watching.
He's judging.
Bada, bada, bada, bada, bada.
Bada, bada, bada, bada.
Let's see.
That's great.
I can't put one on top of the fence, which kind of sucks,
but...
I could just have a monkey out here and be like, yep.
Let's see.
Maybe Ninja Monkey would be good at the end.
That guy's fast.
Wait, can I do more than one on here?
Well, I don't know.
Hey, Ninja Monkey, you're supposed to be fast!
We're losing lives!
You're supposed to be fast!
The ice monkey, I meant he did nothing wrong.
He did not- he brought coleslaw to the barbecue, okay?
He brought coleslaw to the barbecue.
Oh my god, ninja monkey.
Ninja monkey, what is wrong with you?
We're gonna die at this rate.
Whoa!
There's so many.
Potato salad is much better.
Exactly!
I'm hearing my name.
Are you a slaw?
Did you just dox yourself?
First name, coal, last name, slaw?
Oh!
Nice.
Is that bad?
I'm familiar with barbecue etiquette.
At a minto barbecue.
No slaw, no slaw, no slaw.
No coal slaw.
Oh,
you're making me one chicken salad.
Try making a custom map with chat sometime.
The map editor is pretty goofy.
I have to...
Here, let's see.
I'm just gonna...
We'll get through these rounds.
We'll see if we make it to round 40.
And then, um...
I think what?
I think it's 6,000 monkey bucks?
I will pay for more monkey bucks if I have to.
kimchi kosla i'll be honest i don't think i've ever had
kimchi before because it's always spite it's always spicy
he's doing it oh my god he's doing it having a ninja monkey
was so great
oh come on ninja monkey why'd you let that guy slip past you
yes yes I think we're gonna make it.
Oh, I have so much money.
Why am I not upgrading?
I have so much money.
Donating to Min's legal defense for the Tuturu case.
Thank you.
Thank you, Xenopal.
Appreciate it.
Nice.
He's faster.
He's stronger.
Oh, wait.
This one we're going with the top.
I'm surprised he got all of those.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Oh, we got this in the bag, everybody.
We got this in the bag.
Doesn't have to be spicy.
Okay.
I had some soggy kimchi from a jar and it was okay.
Maybe worth trying again.
Maybe it's supposed to be soggy from a jar.
I don't know.
Being in a custom map doesn't give you any monkey money
because you could just make the longest map possible and
trivial clear any game mode for...
Oh, I guess that's fair.
Here we go.
Yippee!
We did it.
Easy peasy.
Lemon squeezy!
Let's go see how much it is and how much I got.
Oh wait, I have almost 5,000 monkey bucks.
And it is 6,000.
or it's seven dollars if i buy more i would need two
thousand more i just do the five thousand one i guess
not worth
fifty dollars for fifty thousand mountain of monkey money
that's insane you'll need a team of monkey shirt was to
reach the summit of this awesome mountain on monkey money
why does it have a description
go for the sale i'm not gonna lie i was kind of looking at
the sale
don't do it but but i want to make our own maps you guys i
want us to create a map together We can make a metal gear
Map Those don't exist I've looked them up already
Monkey money funds No Garlamo Don't do it Please Don't give
me any Please Not for monkey Don't Not for monkey
It's only $12
They're a cool dev team Yeah they give us a lot of stuff i
guess i don't know shadow moses map or grozny grad map
granini granini granini granini granini gorge map
monkey no how much did the base game cost i think it was a
seven dollars i don't remember how much it was when i bought
it embrace your inner monkey it's a 12 tax right No, you
guys, here's some money so you can make a weapon that
surpasses monkey gear.
Usually, okay, this is my thought process.
This is my thought process with games.
When a game, well, this one isn't free to play, but I
usually have this kind of mentality with like gotcha games.
Like, for example, like I'm blue archive, I'm sensei.
is free to play you know like if it's a gotcha game but i
and i enjoy it so much i'll like throw like five bucks a
month at it you know because i'm like you know it's
providing me entertainment and fun and so i'm just like i
wanted to continue so i get when people are like oh i don't
spend any money on gotcha games but i'm just like but i
wanted to keep going high roller i know right i spend how
much i feel the game is worth to me it's how they get you
yeah but i like i do it in moderation now that's on you
that's on you if you can't if you get got in that spider web
that's on you you are providing me entertainment and fun and
i want you to continue oh my god teacup am i gonna see you
again today you guys I saw I saw I met people yesterday it
was so fun
wailing is a skill issue so true but also blue archive is
like so generous I've already gotten the two unique girls
from the free temples but I need Eroha dress
Hina next week?
If I had to prove that your will is weak.
Wait, let's see.
How much was Bloons on here?
Let's see.
Store page.
Bloons?
No, no, no.
Bloons is $14?
What?
$14?
I will not be the monkey money no way okay i spent 14 on
your game and you're gonna make me pay for more monkey
money they increase the price due to the updates oh i was
gonna say i did not spend that much on it miyakari thanks
for the 10 gifted that's crazy though i mean they do give
you a good amount of cash like i've i haven't I haven't
spent anything, or rather, I haven't bought any, and I spent
it on Sada and her skin.
So, you know, they do give you a lot of monkey money.
But dang!
Dang!
Oh!
Wait, what?
Uh-oh, wait, what?
Huh?
Hold on.
I'm so sorry about that.
Basically, I saw...
Okay, my phone, I think, did, like, a freaky AI, like,
message thing to be, like, this is what the phone call is
about, something, something.
I was like, huh?
Because I was saying that my cat had an ultrasound today.
I was like, no, that's not possible.
But I actually do have to get going because my cat is out of
his medicine, and I've been waiting a couple days for the
vet to get back to me to refill it so I could go get it.
And, um, Katz Preggie, no, no, he's a man.
I mean, he's got no balls, but he's, um, I've seen his pink
thing, unfortunately.
Unfortunately.
But, um, yeah, they close, uh, relatively soon, so I have to
go and, um, sorry.
I was like, I was like, huh?
But I've been waiting for their phone call.
So I, um, yeah.
Thanks for the stream, Binto.
It's okay.
I didn't intend on having a super duper long stream today
because I was like, wow, I'm going to be doing meet and
greets.
Tomorrow I won't have a stream either.
I'm really sorry because I will be at the convention all
day.
But Sunday, I will be continuing Metal Gear Solid 2.
Probably, maybe I'll start sooner.
Maybe I'll aim to endurance it.
Maybe, maybe.
Actually, I might do that.
Thanks for the panel today and for the stream.
Fracti!
I can't believe you.
I can't believe you wouldn't introduce who you were.
This guy, this guy comes up and is just like, yeah, I'm
probably the oldest wisp here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'm just like, wait, what's your name?
And he's just like, I'm Membu number two.
And I saved all the Membu cards, but they were in a
different folder that I thought, so I couldn't find it at
the moment.
And I had to go digging, and I was like, yeah, it was you!
Membo number two?
I'll never forget that.
I'll never forget that now.
He made you work.
I know!
He lied.
It was me, Minto.
I'm the oldest.
Who's Membo number one?
That's Paige.
Who's around here sometimes.
But wait, if you went to Offkai, you maybe met Paige.
Yeah.
I remember, I remember, I remember, I remember.
I remember, I remember, I remember.
I try to remember you guys, even though I couldn't remember
number two.
Anyway, thank you guys for Bloonson with me.
You know what, we're going to try harder with the Ice Monkey
Challenge next time.
We will.
We will complete the Ice Monkey Challenge in some capacity.
We will have it done.
But I'm going to take a break from bloons for a while since
I'm, you know.
Since I was like, ah.
I don't know.
It's so weird because this is like usually my, like, comfy
game.
But I'm kind of bloonsed out.
Maybe that's why I am bloonsed out because I've played it
too much.
I bet there are some people cheering.
They're just like, no baboons yeah oh this is what happens
when i have no minecraft you guys weedy welcome to
membership thank you too much of a good thing maybe terraria
that might be fine
okay i'm gonna go get my cats medicine that was i guess good
timing ish because i um yeah uh yeah warthorn is thanks for
inviting thank you thank you Luigi Mansion Luigi Luigi
Mansion this is what no Minecraft does to an MF Mint Phantom
thank you guys for hanging out with me and I will see you
guys uh Sunday Sunday Sunday Sunday Metal Gear probably all
day oh Metal Gear, Altair, Metal Gear, Altair, Altair,
Altair, oh, but also, if you do want some Minto action
tomorrow, the panel that Ayami and I will be a part of at
Anime Fest Dallas will be streamed on Twitch, so you can see
the both of us there as well.
We have a little funny, fun panel that Ayami Sensei actually
thought of, so.
Also, oh my gosh, I asked her, we've been trying to do this
for a while, but having it, we wanted to have an off collab
and now since i'm going to be in japan for like a long a
long time we're gonna do it we're gonna have an off collab
so if you guys have any suggestions on what kind of off
collab you would like for us to do always feel free to
suggest that with me and ayami sensei so marriage stream oh
my gosh what if we could go to a shooting range
In Japan?
Yeah, there are shooting ranges in Japan.
I don't know how we would film that, though, or how we would
stream that, though.
Maybe I can take a video of it.
Maybe we can go together and I'll take a video.
Or something.
My first ever shooting range, too.
ASMR.
We'll see.
we'll see anyway okay thank you guys i'm gonna try since
i'll be in japan for a while too i'm gonna try and get lots
of like fun stuff filmed as well and um uh filmed and i'll
of course keep streaming i have i actually actually because
i will i actually got the i got i got um a better hotel
But yeah, for real this time, for real this time.
And hopefully I won't get sick.
Okie dokie.
Thank you guys.
I will see you guys later.
Have a good night.
If I see you at the convention, at Anime Fest in a couple
hours with the...
With the...
Ablee-le-le-le-le-le-le-le-le-le-le-le-le-le-le.
Meet and greet.
I'll see you then.
Otzumi-ta!
It's T'erai-mosei!
Gotzumi-tama, Otzumi-ta-ta!
Bye-bye!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Bye!
You can still hear me.
Bye-bye, bye-bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye.